[Musique]
je suis autodidacte je viens d'une
famille de musiciens quatre enfants
quatre musiciens nous avons tous
commencé petit on a pris des coups au
sermac avec monsieur jacky alpha on a
commencé à la batterie et après moi je
suis passé au piano mon coffret passée
est restée à la batterie de petits faits
restait à la guitare et madame soleil
était bassiste donc voilà c'est comme ça
que c'est arrivé puis on a persévéré on
a continué aujourd'hui
[Musique]
vous
ma vie
jours on aura peut-être toute la famille
ensemble à pourquoi pas parce que
c'était le cas est un petit peu ce qu'on
avait un groupe qui s'appelle qui
s'appelait teenagers domine aujourd'hui
on a deux comme celle crous et mon petit
frère et moi on a senti un projet
l'année dernière
il sentit le jour de la fête de la
musique qui s'appelle twins addicts du
comme seul coup c'est l'album avec pas
mal de joe dessus avec michael guillon
dont le clip vient de sortir
le manceau femme de mes rêves de gosses
on continue on fait notre notre petit
bonhomme de chemin et puis voilà quoi
donner aux jeunes parents ses rêves et
ne jamais abandonner
coincé le fond c'est ne pas voilà je
sens et c'est tout chercher à réaliser
ses gains